twenty-five airlines including major US
carriers cancelled all flights to
mainland China
they've also suspended some flights to
and from dozens of other cities
including London Milan and Dubai Delta
and American Airlines are waiving fees
for people who wish to change certain
flights travel experts and the point sky
CEO Brian Kelly join us at the table
with what you need to know Ryan good
morning good morning so if you're
concerned hearing the news about the
spread of Crona virus and you have big
plans coming up as a lot of people do
with Spring Break and Passover in
eastern what do you do what's your
what's your first step well I mean it's
still safe to travel there's only four
countries in the world that the CDC is
saying you know only essential travel so
I would say you know I would go on with
plans of course educate yourself these
you know the situation changes daily but
by and large it is still safe to travel
so the airlines are waiving fees we
heard which is not the same as giving a
refund so they're basically saying we
can change it for you but you got a
stand you list among you know Delta just
announced for all international flights
booked starting yesterday they'll waive
change fees so JetBlue is also trying to
build back that confidence and allowing
more flexible changes so do you have
practical advice about what we can do
when we're on the plane I'm thinking the
middle seat probably not middle so yeah
so the the biggest thing about this
virus is exposure being around in close
contact with other people so generally
try to get a window seat and if you've
got points upgrade to premium economy or
even business class when you think about
having your own pod wipe it down wash
your hands and really if you want to be
proactive is bring your own food and
drink on the plane yeah it's a less
interaction there have been flight
attendants who have come down with the
virus so of course they're exposed all
over the place yeah exactly so if you
limit your if you really want to be
overly protective limit your
interactions with others try to get a
seat that's further away all of these
things can help do you think the impact
is likely to be on the airline industry
canceling this many you know we just saw
a report today that 90% of people still
are have not canceled their plans of
course as it develops and people get
more and more scared that could change
but I you know I think there's a lot
more panic going around than is the
actual reality I've flown twice this
week you know maybe one percent of
people are wearing masks
yeah you mentioned business class I mean
that's a
pricey ticket should people be using
points or considering using points to
get there it's a great time we just did
a study 64 percent of business class
seats we've seen it a lot more
availability using your frequent flyer
miles because companies like Facebook
and Twitter are telling their employees
to stay home meaning those first-class
seats are actually available and for
using points so it could be a good time
you didn't get this is likely to affect
ticket prices absolutely we've seen you
know make them go down hotel occupancy
in Hong Kong right now is in single
digit occupancy now I just saw a friend
who's at the Four Seasons for $150
somewhere so look you know if you are
open to traveling this could be the best
time to get a great deal what about you
we're drilling me in the green room
about connecting flights I thought about
that so one of the things you should
look at you don't want to connect
through China a lot a lot of times if
you're going to bali or somewhere in
asia connecting on the chinese airlines
can be very cheap but even if you
connect in an airport in china you're
gonna get additional scrutiny and
screening probably won't be able to go
back to work so factor in that into the
price cheap can be very expensive we
don't know how long this outbreak is
gonna last and people may be buying
travel insurance you know to guard
against that risk what is that what so
no travel insurance most travel
insurance won't cover a pandemic or
epidemic what you do want is cancel for
any reason it's generally about twelve
to fourteen percent of the total trip
costs and you're not gonna get a full
refund
they only refund usually up to
seventy-five percent so you're still
taking a hit so try to book refundable
hotels and airfare and if you do want to
cancel flight and it's non-refundable
don't just cancel it cuz you're gonna
lose the value wait and see the airlines
are changing day by day yeah to be nice
and call the airline and say hey can you
cancel this even if they don't have an
official policy you might get a nice
agent yes or just wait and see because
there could be weather that cancels
[Music]
thank you very much